bonjour à tous dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre l'audition de
stéphane le foll le ministre de
l'agriculture a été auditionné par les
sénateurs de la commission des affaires
économiques mardi commission présidée
par le sénateur socialiste daniel raoul
le ministre est venu défendre son budget
2014 ainsi que la réforme de la pac la
politique agricole commune les aides
européennes à la france dans le domaine
de l'agriculture sont relativement
préservée selon le ministre elles
baissent de 2 % passant de 9,3 milliards
d'euros à 9,1 milliards d'euros c'est le
premier pilier de la pac les aides
directes aux agriculteurs qui devrait
être le plus touché
en revanche le deuxième pilier le
développement rural doit être lui
préservé tout de suite donc retour à
cette audition qui s'est déroulée mardi
au sénat
quel est le d'abord le contexte le
contexte c'est que on va mettre en place
une nouvelle politique agricole commune
qui sera complète
dans sa mise en oeuvre en 2015 au 1er
janvier 2015
ça comprendra les grandes modifications
du premier pilier de la pac et celle du
2e pilier
vous le savez qu'en termes budgétaires
on a dans ce débat européen jamais
facile et dans le contexte de l'europe
d'aujourd'hui peut-être plus difficile
encore que d'habitude obtenu pour la
france un volume dead 1er 2e pilier qui
passera de 9 milliard 3 à 9 milliards 1
c'est à dire une baisse de 2% j'aurais
juste vous rappeler que dans le même
temps l'allemagne verra son budget pour
l'agriculture baissé de 7% 7 % et qu'en
moyenne les pays qui sont ceux de
l'ancienne europe des cases voient leur
budget de l'agriculture baissé de 4%
ce budget sur 1er 2e pilier nous amène à
avoir une potentialité sur le premier
pilier de l'ordre de 7 milliards 7
contre 8 milliards précédemment et sur
le 2e pilier
alors qu'on avait comme année de
référence 2013 1 3 milliard d'euros
on passera les 1,4 milliard d'euros
en fait dans ce débat c'est très
important de bien comprendre que une
partie de ce que nous avons obtenu dans
le débat européen en plus et sur le
deuxième pilier de la politique agricole
commune
c'est ça qu'il faut intégrer parce que
dans le débat budgétaire
ça aura des incidences à partir de l'art
sur la pac
on est en cours de négoce de discussion
sur les éléments d'arbitrage est
essentielle à la mise en oeuvre de la
pac en 2015 en particulier sur la
question du premier pilier de sa
politique eric ont comme vous le savez
il va y avoir des changements majeurs
notre système agricole des aides à
l'hectare passera de ce qu'on appelle
les dpu c'est à dire des aides
historique à un système totalement
nouveau qui s'appelle les des bébés les
les droits de paiement de base
j'ai fini par oublier qu'elle était la
signification du sigle et cd pb par
rapport aux dpu quel est le changement
le plus important c'est que le choix de
l'europe c'est de ramener l'ensemble des
aides à l'hectare vers une moyenne à
l'échelle européenne pour au bout du
compte aboutir c'était ça l'objectif au
même paiement à l'hectare quel que soit
les pays quelles que soient les régions
de l'europe à partir de l'art dans un
pays comme le nôtre qui sort des
références historiques
on passe d'un système où on pouvait
avoir des aides à l'hectare de 450 à 500
euros l'hectare alors que dans d'autres
régions et en particulier dans le
sud-est
on était autour de 150 140 150 euros
l'hectare convergé vers la moyenne
c'est ce qu'on appelle la convergence
des aides vous pouvez le faire à 100%
c'est à dire d'ici 2020 à faire en sorte
que toutes les aides à l'hectare versés
en france soit ramené à la moyenne pour
tous les hectares où vous pouvez le
faire partiellement
c'est ce qui a été choisi par le
président de la république avec une
convergence à 70 poussons pour une
raison très simple c'est passé de
référence historique à la même aide à
l'hectare pour tout le monde ça
nécessite bien entendu des effets de
transfert entre ceux qui avaient des dpu
élevé et ce qu'avait des dpu faible et
que pour ceux qui avaient des dp mais
élevé je pense en particulier au grant
west et quand je dis grant west c'est le
nord le pas de calais jusque en bas les
pyrénées atlantiques
on avait besoin d'assurer une transition
donc on a choisi une convergence de 70%
tiers qu'on fera pas la totalité du
chemin de la convergence d'ici 2020 on
leur a fait à hauteur de 70% cirque on a
rapproché les aides les plus élevés vers
la moyenne et remonter les aides des
plus basses vers la moyenne
ça c'est le premier débat il a été
arbitrée par une prison dorée publique
sur ce sujet il n'y a pas de discussion
deuxième débat où il ya encore des
discussions et c'est très important que
vous sachiez
c'est sur la question du couplage des
aides
on s'est battus je me suis battu à
l'échelle européenne pour refuser l'idée
du découplage générale des aides depuis
longtemps d'ailleurs
et dans le débat et la négociation entre
les ministres de l'agriculture
j'ai fait en sorte que sur la question
du couplage non seulement on maintienne
à niveau de couplage mais qu'on augmente
la proposition qui avait été faite par
la commission au départ des négociations
et la proposition de la commission était
de maintenir 10 % d'être couplé nous
avons en deux étapes fait progresser le
taux de 12% à 13% grâce au parlement
européen en y ajoutant deux points de
couplage et ça c'est important
sur la question des protéines
fourragères et ça c'est un sujet qui
concerne en particulier vous savez
l'autonomie fourragère et la limitation
de la dépendance de l'europe et donc de
la france des protéines fourragère qui
viennent de l'extérieur en particulier
d'amérique latine pour le soja le débat
est en cours avec les organisations
professionnelles parce que sur les 13 %
de couplage aujourd'hui pour maintenir
les aides qui était déjà couple et c'est
à dire la prime à la vache allaitante la
primo veine-là prink caprine et la prime
au lait de montagne
on était déjà à hauteur de 10,6 7% du
premier pilier
il nous en restait donc pratiquement 3%
à distribuer nous y ajoutons la prime
nationale pour la vache allaitante qui
était une prime nationale comme je les
dis sur budget national mais qui était
dérogatoires aux règles européennes
et lorsqu'on a négocié à l'échelle de
l'europe l'augmentation du taux de
couplage des aides
la commission européenne a souhaité
qu'il n'y ait plus de dérogations et
donc on intègre la prime nationale à la
vache allaitante dans les aides couplées
du premier pilier
en france ça fait une économie
budgétaire pour le budget de la nation
mais ça sécurise cette aide de manière
définitive à l'échelle européenne
en faisant ça on est autour de 12 % des
aides et donc il nous reste 1 % des
aides à distribuer et c'est là qu'est le
débat et directrice de la dgpaat la
direction qui gère ça depuis quinze
jours trois semaines a engagé donc une
discussion pour trouver le meilleur
équilibre sur l'utilisation de
l'ensemble de ces aides couplées et en
particulier pour savoir dans ce qui nous
reste deux disponibles à quoi et à
qui ont l'affect il ya une partie de ces
aides je le dis ici devant la commission
du sénat qui doit aller vers les le lait
aient une partie aussi sur un certain
nombre de productions végétales et celle
équilibre général de ce couplage à 13%
qui fait le débat aujourd'hui
sachant que sur les 2% liées aux
protéines fourragères la discussion et
l'a aussi menée pour savoir si on met
ces 2 % uniquement sur un soutien pour
des protéines fourrage est relié
directement à l'élevage ou si dans ces 2
% on en garde aussi une partie pour
développer des filières liées à des
protéagineux des protéines végétales
cette discussion est aussi en cours et
l'arbitrage n'est pas finie donc sur le
premier pilier de la pac qui reste
encore des sujets ça impacte le budget
de l'agriculture au sens où je le disais
tout à l'heure la prime nationale à la
vache allaitante qui était sur le budget
de la france passe ipso facto sur le
budget européen
et si le budget français est affiché à 4
9 milliards d'euros et peut afficher une
baisse de 3,2 pour cent ça ne remet pas
en cause pour les agriculteurs les aides
qu'ils perçoivent aujourd'hui en
particulier sur l'élevage c'est très
important
dernier point c'est des paiements
redistributive c'est à dire l'idée que
dans ce débat on puisse redistribuer une
partie des aides en remontant les aides
à l'hectare sur les 52 premiers hectares
l'idée qu'il y a derrière c'est de faire
en sorte qu'on fasse le choix de garder
une agriculture avec des chefs
d'exploitation c'est-à-dire des
agriculteurs des éleveurs des
producteurs parce que vous l'avez
entendu si je prends l'exemple de ce qui
s'est passé en picardie avec la fameuse
exploitation des millevaches
c'est un investisseur qui investit dans
une production laitière dans le cadre de
la loi
y'a pas de moyens ni au niveau
environnemental ni dans les
établissements cas c'est de remettre en
cause de choix qu'il fait mais si on
laisse aller l'agriculture dans cette
voie eh bien demain la production
agricole sera faite par des gens qui
viendront investir mais il y aura plus à
la tête des exploitations d'agriculteurs
de producteurs ou des peurs et le jour
parce que c'est ça la vraie question ou
ceux qui investissent dit trouveront
plus la rentabilité suffisante et qu'ils
retireront investissement puis là on
risque de se retrouver sans agriculteurs
et sans agriculture donc le choix des 52
premiers hectares si je crois en l'idée
d'un gaec à 3 et bien si on est dans la
transparence parce que c'est ça
l'objectif des grecs
ça fait trois fois 52 ha ça fait cent
cinquante six hectares on peut être sûr
des productions des tiers dans l'ouest
autour de 700 à 800 à 900 mille litres
de quota aujourd'hui de production
c'est-à-dire pratiquement un million dit
mais derrière les 1 millions de litres
il ya trois agriculteurs et si je mets
une majoration sur les 52 premiers
hectares je valorise le fait qu' il faut
garder 3 agri tout agriculteur
plutôt que de passer à deux plutôt que
de passer 1 c'est ça qui a derrière la
logique des 52 premiers hectares c'est
qu'on fait le lien entre des aides à
l'hectare
et puis derrière l'emploi agricole mais
l'emploi agricole je le dis parce que ça
c'est très important de chefs
d'exploitation de producteurs d'éleveurs
alors ça fait un effet redistributif
bien sûr pour les plus grandes
exploitations sa redistribue vers les
premiers hectares et en moyenne ça fait
perdre sur au delà de 200 hectares mais
dans l'esprit et dans l'objectif les
projets qu'on a pour l'aviculture
c'est un choix stratégique majeur
conflit et le président de la république
a indiqué dans le discours de cournon
que ce que nous allons mobiliser sur ces
premiers hectares c'est 20 % du premier
pilier c'est à dire un milliard et demi
et on le fera de manière progressive
puisque il faut aussi qu'on tienne
compte de la mise en oeuvre sa s'agit
pas de brutaliser ce qui existe s'agit
de faire évoluer
l'agriculture française c'est un grand
grand paquebot à grands pétroliers
on lui fait pas tourner on ne fait pas
tourner à angle droit on lui fait
prendre des angles et on l'orienté c'est
ça qui a été fait sur le 2e pilier
sas a des conséquences importantes on a
négocié des choses qui vont se mettre en
oeuvre dans la phase de transition
en 2014 c'est important aussi dans le
débat budgétaire en particulier on a
fait remonter ce qu'on appelle des taux
de cofinancement
c'est à dire le fait que l'europe va
payer la part de l'europe dans les
financements du 2e pilier sera plus
élevée que ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'était 55 ans 50 budget
national 50 budget européen selon les
cas on est passé de 70 à 80% de
cofinancement et pourquoi on peut le
faire sans remettre en cause l'ensemble
des dispositifs qui existent parce que
je voulais indiqué tout à l'heure le
niveau du budget européen sur le 2e
pilier est plus élevé que ce que nous
avions avant terre on peut monter le
cofinancement sans remettre en cause
l'ensemble des dispositifs parce que on
a un peu plus de marge sur le 2e pilier
de la politique agricole commune et dans
le débat budgétaire c'est très important
là aussi dans l'objectif de la maîtrise
des dépenses publiques sans remettre en
cause les politiques pour les
agriculteurs en montant le cofinancement
européen on diminue le budget national à
la part du financement du budget
national
sans remettre en cause les politiques
qui sont conduites ça sera le cas pour
l'indemnité compensatrice de handicap
ça sera le cas pour les mesures agro
environnementales
ça sera le cas pour la politique
d'installation pour les jeunes on
maintient le budget en particulier sur
l'installation 300 millions d'euros
mais on fait jouer ce différentiel donc
j'intègre comme ça et la question
budgétaire parce que nous sommes dans ce
moment où il faut qu'on soit sérieux
mais en même temps je garantis aux
agriculteurs les objectifs politiques de
ces grandes politiques dont ils ont
besoin je pense en particulier indemnité
compensatrice de handicap qu'on
revalorise aussi en même temps qu'on
revalorise pour obtenir ce qu'a dit le
président de la république à cournon
c'est à dire un transfert via la
convergence des aides via le
verdissement via le deuxième pilier d'à
peu près un milliard d'euros vers l'est
vers l'élevage par rapport à ce qui
existe aujourd'hui ces salons jeu et
c'est comme ça qu'on y arrive
et puis je l'évoqué un peu au passage ya
la question du verdissement si les
fameux 30%
on a fait le choix d'un verdissement
fonctionnel par exploitation pourquoi on
a fait ce choix parce que là aussi par
rapport aux la convergence
le fait qu'on ait fait non pas un choix
forfaitaire et bien le choix
proportionnelle permet d'ajuster les 30
% liée au verdissement exploitation par
exploitation
ce qui permet de garantir à ces
exploitations le maintien du niveau de
l'aide liée au verdissement
c'est très important et dense
verdissement vous le savez on va mettre
en place trois mesures
la première concerne les rotations de
cultures où les différences des
différentes cultures couverture le sol 3
et là nous sommes en train de travailler
pour adapter cette mesure en particulier
dans les zones où il ya du maïs en
monoculture alsace et sud ouest pour
trouver des solutions adaptées avec des
couvertures de sol il ya le deuxième
élément c'est le matière des prairies
permanentes et là vous connaissez ce
sujet maintien des prairies permanentes
qui en surface sera regardée à l'échelle
d'une région pas simplement les chefs
d'exploitation cirque on va pouvoir
à ce moment-là moduler et de temps
j'entends retourner des prairies parce
qu'il y en a besoin en termes
agronomique pour les éleveurs et puis le
dernier point c'est des surfaces
d'intérêt écologique à 5% ou là il y à
tout un tas de critères qui sont mises
en place pour faire en sorte que dans
les exploitations on puisse avoir comme
objectif d'avoir 5 % de surfaces
d'intérêt écologie je prends un exemple
la production de chambre qui se
développe en particulier les pays de
loire
aujourd'hui et avec la vendée comme avec
une entreprise de transformation le
champ par exemple ne consomme ni
n'utilise ni azote ni très peu de
fongicides
c'est donc une plante verte en termes du
surface d'intérêt écologique
il est très intéressant de la développer
parce que derrière il ya des capacités à
développer des matériaux sains qui sont
extrêmement utiles en particulier pour
l'isolation des maisons
si on veut économiser l'énergie on peut
utiliser du chant et c'est pas une
plaisanterie donc premier deuxième vie
les politiques agricoles et budget vous
voyez bien le lien qui lie à entre les
deux
dans ce qui est le budget on reste sur
les grandes priorités qui était celle
d'ailleurs qu'on avait évoqué l'an
dernier et qu'il faut garder bien à
l'esprit à la fois la question de la
compétitivité de l'agriculture
je suis pas oublié ce sujet et se
cumulera cette année pour 2014
deux mesures à la fois le théo des oeufs
et le crédit d'impôt compétitivité
emploi est là pour la compétitivité de
notre agriculture c'est un élément
important
ça représente 1,3 milliard d'euros dé
forces sur la compétitivité de
l'agriculture et l'agroalimentaire or
jean-claude y est là ensuite on a sur la
question de l'agroécologie je n'ai pas
oublié non plus ce qu'est le projet que
nous portons à la fois sur la question
des mae les mesures agro
environnementales et là on viendra
présenter présidence le président quand
vous le souhaiterez les nouveaux
systèmes de m abbas est intéressant que
vous ayez en tête la manière dont on va
aborder ce qu'on appelle les mae système
savez qu'aujourd'hui les mesures
agro-environnementales c'est je vous
donne de l'argent pour que vous fassiez
une politique sur une petite surface qui
soit environnementalement compatibles et
l'a priori de base c'est quand on fait
des environnements ça coûte plus cher et
donc il faut une aide ce qu'on veut
mettre en place pour l'agriculture de
demain c'est le fait que l'écologie et
l'environnement soient moteur d'économie
en termes de production et qu'on
maintienne le niveau de la production et
qu'on baisse les coûts de la production
c'est ça l'enjeu et les mae système
c'est une manière dont des tentes qu'on
est en train de construire pour donner
aux agriculteurs une dynamique positive
une à une écologie qui mobilise
mobilisatrice et pas simplement une
écologie normative ou une écologie au
travers de la fiscalité je pense que
c'est un bas un débat qui mérite
vraiment qu'on s'y attarde
l'agroécologie avec l'enseignement
agricole avec la recherche à l'inra
c'est un enjeu prioritaire et donc ça
reste l'objectif que nous nous sommes
fixés je parle pas des plans qu'on a
lancée sur
lambie ambitions bio qui reste en mise
en oeuvre par rapport à ce qu'on a fait
en 2012 et puis tout ce qui concerne
aussi l'apiculture ici il ya le
président du nouveau comité de pilotage
stratégique pour l'apiculture qu'on a
mis en place c'est un enjeu aussi
important
ensuite l'installation des jeunes je
voulais dit on maintient l'objectif 300
millions d'euros
avec toujours un objectif élevé durera
la possibilité d'ailleurs de mettre sur
le premier pilier premier pilier 2e
pilier les moyens sur l'installation des
jeunes
moi je pense que on doit aboutir à terme
à des objectifs autour de huit à dix
mille installations
j'ai regardé les chiffres qui sont
sortis sur 2012 on a douze mille
installations et 6000 installations dans
le cadre des dotations des aides un des
aides à l'installation 6000 pour 12000
vous savez que avec les organisations de
jeunes au niveau agricole et les gia on
a fait une charte qui a débouché sur des
assises de l'installation
on a changé les règles mais c'est très
intéressant de se le dire on est passé
par exemple la surface minimum
d'installation à la alama c'est-à-dire
l'activité minimale d'assujettissement
c'est à dire que pour s'installer
maintenant on va pas prendre que la
surface on va regarder qu'est ce que
c'est que l'activité
qu'est ce qui se dégage comme revenu
parce que c'est très important de
pouvoir mettre en perspective le fait
que l'installation n'est plus lié
uniquement à la surface
elle est liée à ce qui est capable de
dégager un jeune qui s'installe en
termes de revenus c'est un vrai
changement un vrai sujet qui définira
peut-être demain aussi ce qu'est l'actif
en agriculture puisque derrière hamage
les 10es activité minimale
d'assujettissement et cette activité
minimale d'assujettissement permet
d'être assujetti justement à la haye les
sa et par la msa
on pourra aussi avoir une idée plus
claire de ce qu'est latif en agriculture
puisque c'est un sujet qui nous concerne
et qui vous concerne tous il ya aussi
dans ce budget est dans la loi d'avenir
un grand volet sur la forêt
il ya des spécialistes ici je vois
soulisse président monsieur du luart
quitte ici on a l'a fait un choix
stratégique sur la forêt avec un conseil
supérieur de la forêt on a intégré la
forêt filière économique de ministère de
l'industrie
et là on crée pour la première fois un
fonds stratégique pour la forêt on met
en place un système d'orientation de
l'epargne qui s'appellera sifa qui va
permettre je le dis aux spécialistes de
faire en sorte que les avantages fiscaux
qui sont alloués aujourd'hui à des
propriétaires lorsque le bois et sur
pied puisse être transférée sur un
compte
lorsque le bois est coupée l'idée c'est
de faire en sorte que les propriétaires
privés puissent à partir de là sortir le
bois qu'ils possèdent qu on passe d'une
logique de patrimonial à une logique
économique et ce compte spécial nouveau
sifa est une innovation je pense
importante qui permettra aussi de
renforcer la dimension et économique
tout en ayant l'ensemble des éléments de
la forêt en compte mais nous souhaitons
par delà le fonds stratégique par delà
cette question d'epargne mobilisables
qui mobilise en fait le bois activé
cette production qui en france
aujourd'hui vous savez connaît un
déficit commercial de 6 milliards
d'euros
on explore débit on a aussi bien sur un
plan d'investissement pour les scieries
on est en train de discuter aussi avec
le mystère l'environnement pour
permettre aux scieries d'avoir des
possibilités d'avoir les accès aux prix
ah bon le prix de rachat sur l'énergie
pour faire de la cogénération tout ça ça
procède du même principe développer
cette filière faire de l'activité faire
en sorte que la forêt devienne un
secteur économique à part entière en
même temps qu'elle aura aussi à garantir
des grands enjeux liés à l'écologie la
biodiversité est aussi tout ce qui est
lié au tourisme et aux loisirs puisque
la forêt c'est important sur
l'enseignement agricole
je reste sur la ligne
quand il avait évoqué l'an dernier
l'enseignement agricole va participer au
produire autrement à cette grande
ambition sur l'agroécologie on créera
150 postes supplémentaires 30 postes
d'auxiliaires de vie c'est important et
20 postes au niveau de l'enseignement
supérieur renforce ce pôle c'est
important et je le vois moi quand je me
déplace à l'international il y à là les
vraies potentialités pour la france de
rayonner au delà de l'hexagone
on est regardés l'enseignement agricole
est quelque chose sur lequel beaucoup de
pays souhaite signer des conventions de
partenariat avec la france
on a là un vrai potentiel il faut que
l'on joue à fond enfin ce cet objectif
qui lie à la fois la politique agricole
commune
le budget de l'agriculture et la
question de la loi d'avenir c'est au
fond faire en sorte que l'agriculture
puisse assurer pour notre pays
la part qui est la sienne dans ce
redressement productif dont redressement
économique de ce pays
avec derrière l'agroalimentaire ça va de
soi et sur la bretagne
on connaît les discussions qui a
aujourd'hui on a aussi la nécessité de
faire en sorte de garantir une
pérennisation des activités que ce soit
dans la volaille export que ce soit dans
les productions nouvelles de qualité que
ça soit dans le la question de la
méthanisation qui pour moi est un enjeu
essentiel en bretagne dans les pays de
loire mais partout en france
j'entends souvent vous savez on parle
des gages de schiste on dire il faut
aller fracturée à 3000 mètres de
profondeur avec de la fabrique de
fracturation hydraulique c'est quand
même fantastique que depuis 10 15 ans
nous on est loupé le fait qu'on a du gaz
dans la matière organique qui est
produite en france et qu'on n'est pas
capable de le valoriser pour faire de
l'énergie renouvelable ça c'est un sujet
pour moi qui doit être une priorité
je suis sûr que dans tous les bons de
cette assemblée on sera d'accord pour
dire il faut qu'on rattrape
ce retard a un sens et l'allemagne à
7000 méthaniseur on en a 80
c'est pas possible c'est de
l'investissement c'est d'activité c'est
de la création de filières et ça c'est
disponible et c'est de l'énergie qui est
chez nous c'est du gaz que nous avons
donc là il faut qu'on soit extrêmement
volontariste et c'est pourquoi aussi
dans cet objectif
on a des propositions qui sont en cours
de mise en oeuvre sur les éléments
réglementaires qui vont avec
et puis je terminerai sur les questions
sanitaires ce jeu l'oublier moi je reste
très vigilant après ce qui nous est
arrivé sur la viande de cheval et toutes
ces questions sanitaires dans le budget
je vous le dis l'objectif c'est de
maintenir le nombre de postes des
services vétérinaires pour assurer le
contrôle de la qualité des produits
parce que c'est un sujet sur lequel on
ne peut pas transiger même si le
ministre de l'agriculture fait des
efforts en termes de réductions
d'effectifs sur ce poste là j'ai
considéré de pitch est arrivé qu'il
fallait stopper ce qui avait été engagé
et faire en sorte qu'on maintienne un
niveau suffisant pour assurer la
sécurité sanitaire
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire ça
fait beaucoup de choses mais je vous
laisse la parole vous êtes trop bon sur
le ministre
j'ai au moins le 5 premières auditions
qui sont des rapporteurs que soit de la
commission des affaires économiques au
la commission des finances mais en
priorité le vice prime cieux le
président guillaume votre guise si vous
avez une question à poser à monsieur le
ministre pour que vous puissiez
président est tout de suite dans
l'enchaînement désolé il faut que
j'aille remplacer jean pierre raffarin à
17 heures donc je ne pourrais pas rester
donc je veux bien ne pas poser de
questions parce que c'est ce serait une
impolitesse notoire simplement une
réflexion si vous le permettez en deux
minutes pour dire que aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit très bien faire aujourd'hui
comme hier mais ça va aller en
s'accélérant que lorsqu'on parle
d'agriculture et de budget on doit
parler de budget de la france en parler
de budget de l'europe et que le cercle
l'ensemble c'est un paquet qui fait que
cela permet d'avoir des actions
agricoles et économiques qui sont
importantes et monsieur le ministre vous
l'avez très bien dire et bravo d'avoir
réussi à maintenir à l' as été auteur là
le budget de la politique agricole
commune
c'est pas gagné d'avancé et pris des
crampes a raison avec d'autres d'autres
d'autres pays
et merci d'avoir mecque du slap pas pour
nous mais pour nos agriculteurs
parce que si le budget de la pac comme
on nous l'annonçait deux avait baissé ça
aurait été je pense pour notre pays une
catastrophe
alors il est maintenu vous avez un
budget national qui lorsqu on le
construit des lexus de la pac permet de
faire des actions
à nous d'être suffisamment intelligent
pour permettre que par les paiements
redistributif par une nouvelle façon
d'appréhender l'agriculture en mettant
toujours en avant évidemment l'aspect
économique sans aspect économique on ne
s'en sort pas sans exportations ne s'en
sort pas mais en mettant évidemment
navan l'agroécologie qui est absolument
indispensable
nous arrivions à avancer pour une
agriculture à la fois durables lunel
culture qui fait vivre ces agriculteurs
et dans ce sens là monsieur le ministre
que vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure sur
dans le cadre de la pac sur les sur les
50 premiers hectares est à mon sens
essentiel ça peut être une difficulté
pour certains mais le tac et des 30% on
va permettre d'atténuer les choses ça
peut être une difficulté mais il
n'empêche que si nous voulons demain des
agriculteurs
heures sur des fermes alors il faut
absolument mieux doter les 50 premiers
hectares pour éviter l'exemple de la
somme ou je sais pas ou que vous
évoquiez la halle à la ferme de
millevaches
mais surtout de permettre d'avoir des
jeunes et je termine en disant que si
nous voulons avoir encore du lendemain
et des jeunes
alors il faut il faut de la formation et
il faut consolider l'enseignement
agricole qui est essentiel au aussi pour
notre peau notre pays donc je veux pas
du tout on dire en dire plus
j'aurais aimé vous poser des questions
mais je ne le ferai pas parce que ne
pouvant pas écouter les réponses par
politesse je préfère laisser mes
collègues faire ce travail tout cas je
voulais vous remercier
si madame renée nicoux et ensuite gérard
césar les deux coprésidents oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
que vous avez répondu à beaucoup des
questions que l'on se posait concernant
la pac mais je voulais dire qu'à un
moment où il est impératif de redresser
les comptes publics où des efforts sont
demandés à tous les ministères ce budget
vous avez réussi avec ce budget à
maintenir les grands équilibres
nécessaires au développement de
l'agriculture
malgré une réduction réduction du budget
elle et qui est limité et que l'on
explique ou que vous venez d'expliquer
par la rationalisation de la police des
politiques agricoles et par la mise en
oeuvre de la nouvelle pac avec
l'accroissement des co financements
communautaires pour certains dispositifs
mais on peut souligner qu'il y a une
réelle volonté politique de donner tous
les crédits nécessaires à l'installation
des jeunes agriculteurs de développer
les mesures agro-environnementales de
soutenir l'élevage de mettre l'accent
sur le volet sanitaire et phytosanitaire
c'est ce que vous venez de préciser de
développer l'enseignement agricole en
augmentant les effectifs notamment
d'enseignants de créer les conditions
nécessaires au développement de la forêt
en créant un fonds stratégique de la
forêt et du bois
donc vraiment une politique volontariste
malgré ces points positifs j'aurai
quelques questions quelques points qui
mérite quelques explications notamment
ce qui concerne la forêt il est précisé
que ce fonds stratégique sera abondé par
une taxe une nouvelle taxe au
défrichement donc si vous pouviez nous
donner quelques explications quant à
cette taxe à quoi il correspond et
comment elles s'appliquent
je pense que ce serait utile pour pour
nous tous et puis quelques points qui
soulève questions notamment les crédits
de crise
agressif par exemple qui sont maintenus
à un niveau relativement bas et la
question qu'on peut se poser compte tenu
du contexte économique actuel seront ils
suffisants et est ce que vous pourriez
nous dire de quelle manière ont été
dépensés les crédits agridiff cette
année si on a quelques
renseignements sur ce point les crédits
pmb eux qui sont maintenus à 46 millions
d'euros pour la deuxième année en
autorisations d'engagement et de 30
millions pour les
celle inverse à 30 millions en a eu
est-ce que cela ne risque pas
d'entraîner une limitation de ces
crédits pour les années à venir et que
cela soit insuffisant j'aurais voulu
aussi abordé les crédits franceagrimer
qui se passe de 97 millions d'euros à 87
même s'il y a 10 millions de prix sur le
qatar on avait remarqué l'année dernière
que cela risque d'être un peu juste et
est ce qu'ils seront suffisants pour
leur permettre une véritable politique
de communication sur les différentes
filières et enfin je terminerai par une
question mais vous avez en partie
répondu sur ce point là sur les crédits
et la pac
donc le bleu budgétaire prévoit de
mettre davantage à contribution les
crédits européens pour compenser la
baisse de crédits nationaux
elle ne craignez vous pas que le
deuxième pilier de la pac ne dispose pas
d'assez de crédit pour faire face à
l'ensemble des besoins comme par exemple
celui résultant de l'augmentation de 15%
pour les hisser à chaîne et je laisserai
la place à d'autres pour synthétiser
puisque beaucoup de questions vont se
poser
merci monsieur gérard césar nous sommes
mis d'accord et curling ou pour une même
question est le couple vers et non sur
l'agriculture rapport en question ses
ministres et la première question je
voulais poser quel est l'impact sur
l'écouteur du relèvement du taux de tva
sous les engrais que ça importe le
justement donc le prix de revient des
agriculteurs deuxième question quel
bilan tirez-vous du recentrage de la dpi
en 2013 et surtout aborder ce point là
des pays si la dotation prophétisme ans
je traduis et pourquoi pas aller je sais
que vous êtes assez favorable se mesure
à l'est sur la dpa plutôt que la dpi ça
ça me paraît être une mesure tout à fait
intéressante
latro question que vous me posez c'est
est combien de crédit ont été
nécessaires en 2016 revendre et le fonds
des calamités agricoles
est-ce que vous avez un chiffre pour
nous dire qu'elle était par rapport aux
calamités agricoles que l'était la
dotation que vous avez pu envisager et
aussi quel avenir
et ça c'est un problème qui est cher à
monsieur emorine quel avenir du soutien
européen la souscription d'assurances
climatique et le problème qui nous est
posée à tous et lorsque vous êtes venus
en gironde
je voulais poser de la réassurance est
un problème très important pour nous
tous est une question de la forêt le
crédit de vnf senti là les crédits à
fonds perdus ou pas est ce qu'on a
vraiment une solution pour améliorer la
gestion du rennais est aussi vous avez
parlé du fonds stratégique la création
je me réjouis de ce la création de ce
fonds stratégique comme tous les
forestiers
mais est-ce qu'il sera suffisant pour
alimenter justement la filière par
rapport donc cette économie du bois que
nous avons tous à coeur de défendre
voilà merci merci né deux derniers à
porter par les commissions des finances
monsieur botrel et monsieur bon merci
monsieur le président bien que vous nous
ayez préconisé de faire vite sur la
crise de l'agroalimentaire en bretagne
comprendrez que j'y vienne un peu dans
cette crise de l'agroalimentaire en
bretagne plus que celles des filières
ancien ministre s'est il s'agit de la
crise de l'outil industriel aussi bien
dans la filière avicole que dans la
filière porcine
je saisis l'occasion pour dire
d'ailleurs que dans la filière agricole
c'est la chronique d'une crise annoncée
puisque depuis 2008 au moins mais même
un peu avant jeudi 2008 parce que
j'avais eu l'occasion d'interpeller
monsieur barnier sur ce sujet celui ci
avait déclaré de façon extrêmement clair
que les restitutions dont les
subventions à l'exportation allait
disparaître
ce que je constate c'est que les
industriels n'ont pas tenu compte de cet
agenda qu'on leur avait indiqué et qu'il
s'agit de leur part d'une sorte de fuite
en avant
je passe le fait qu'ils souhaitent aller
se tenter de se diversifier en amérique
du sud et ça me fait dire que d'une
certaine manière c'est la stratégie
qu'on a pu voir pratiquer dans d'autres
domaines
too big to fail c'est à dire que c'est
la course c'est la fuite en avant se
disant de la part de certaines personnes
que de toute façon les pouvoirs publics
ne pourrait pas laisser tomber dans le
même temps on assiste à un paradoxe
puisque on sent bien que ces
exportations sont du grand export comme
on les nomme son sont condamnés par
défaut de subventions puisque nous
peinons à être compétitif pour un
certain nombre de raisons que je ne vais
pas reprendre mais dans le même temps et
c'est le paradoxe dont je voulais parler
notre marché intérieur de produits
avicoles et largement pénétré désormais
on dit à hauteur de 40% par des viandes
de volailles qui viennent d'autres pays
de la communauté l'espace européen et en
particulier de l'allemagne
alors la question sur le ministre
première question face à cette situation
paradoxale que peut-on faire et pour
adapter l'outil industriel parce qu'on
voit bien qui a là aussi deux agendas ya
le court terme avec l'anxiété et pour ne
pas dire plus des ouvriers les personnes
qui travaillent dans ces abattoirs
il ya donc cet agenda de courtes court
terme et puis un agenda de plus long
terme sur l'adaptation de l'outil
industriel et
c'est intéressant que puissiez nous
donner quelques indications à ce sujet
sur la méthanisation dont vous avez
parlé effet sujet extrêmement important
qui probablement contribué à donner de
la compétitivité à l'allemagne et aux
éleveurs allemands particulièrement les
élevages porcins ma question je la
prends chez un certain nombre de
producteurs de porcs qui ont eu qui vont
être interrogés ou du moins qui m'ont
dit leur préoccupation à ce sujet
l'impression qu'ils ont eu un certain
moment c'est d'avoir affaire à des
résistances ici en france de la part
d'edf en particulier à l'installation de
méthaniseur dans les exploitations
agricoles
je sais pas si les choses ont évolué
donc tout cas je vous pose la question
ensuite le président de la république a
annoncé un fonds de modernisation au
bâtiment d'élevage de points à ce sujet
y at il des bâtiments ciblés plus que
d'autres où tous tous les bâtiments
d'élevage de façon indistincte
peuvent-ils prétendre à bénéficier de ce
fonds de modernisation et
le deuxième question décline de la
première de quelle manière
l'engagement du président de la
république se concrétise style dans le
budget de l'année 2014 et enfin pour
terminer une réflexion qui rejoint mes
propos liminaire ceux de crise des
filières filière agroalimentaire en
bretagne sa question des travailleurs
détachés puisque notre absence de
compétitivité découlent pour une part
également de cette question yat-il
espoirs de quelques avancées sur le
sujet monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur bourdin monsieur le
président je serais assez bref les
redoutables rapporteur qui sont
intervenus avant moi m'ont déjà pris
beaucoup de questions et donc je je n'en
garde que que trois la première concerne
les crédits qui sont prévus pour
franceagrimer et qui sont en réduction
en 2013
ils sont en quelque chose il y à une
compensation qui s'effectue avec le
quasar 1 et qui se comporte bien qu est
une ressource qui a tendance à augmenter
je voudrais savoir monsieur min 6 ans et
concerne le quasar est cette ressource
de compensation on n'est pas dans dans
une évolution conjoncturelle ou est-ce
qu'on est dans une évolution
structurelle c'est à dire un rebasage en
quelque sorte des ressources ducasse
d'art c'est à dire ce qui est prévu pour
2014 est il valable pour les années qui
suivent
deuxième question sur l'eau nf bon lot
nf dont j'ai eu l'occasion de faire un
contrôle ya bien des années sur le nf
qui était en grave difficulté
il ya des difficultés qui persistent
bien sûr et des crédits sont sont
prévues je pense pour améliorer le sort
de l'eau inès en 2014
là encore on devrait savoir la part
qu'il ya entre les effets conjoncturels
effets de structure est ce que l'eau nf
est en train de se refaire une santé
enfin dernière question sur le
biocarburant
il est prévu une suppression de
davantage fiscaux donc il va y avoir
ils ont déséquilibres financiers
différents dans la filière
et donc ma question c'est quid de la
filière biocarburant
merci madame et messieurs les rapporta
sur le ministre on y va donc c'est vrai
qu'on a des rapporteurs qui ont posé
beaucoup de questions extrêmement
précise la première au ni ni coup sûr
des questions du fonds stratégique et du
défrichement sur le aujourd'hui il ya
des possibilités qui sont très claires
lorsqu on défriche on doit reboiser là
les préfets pourront remplacer
l'obligation de reboisement par le
paiement d'une taxe au défrichement donc
c'est un choix du préfet dans certains
départements je prends les landes c'est
des sujets qui sont sensibles mais cette
idée n'est pas du tout là pour
encourager
j'allais dire du défrichement on paye et
puis on se débarrasse non au contraire
elle est là aussi pour récupérer une
partie de ce qui sera lié au
défrichement pour des raisons x ou y et
alimentera en partie le fonds
stratégique qu'est ce qui a bien le
fonds stratégique parce que s'il n'y
avait que les centimes
faurecia des chambres d'agriculture plus
la prime au défrichement
on est autour s'étaient dits de 20
millions d'euros
derrière je le dis ici devant
dessinateur qui vont m'écouter c'est
qu'une fois qu'on a ce portage cet outil
l'objectif c'est quand même un jour
d'avoir une partie du fonds carbone qui
viennent alimenter le fonds stratégique
bois parce que c'est ça qui a derrière
l'objectif il quand même là aussi
aujourd'hui son carbone ça ne fonctionne
pas on a un marché du carbone qui est
extrêmement bas mais la forêt puis
carbone va pas se raconter des histoires
on connaît
tout ça ça doit un jour bénéficier du
fonds du fonds donc ça c'est un débat
qu'aujourd'hui est toujours difficile
d'avoir en particulier lorsqu'on discute
avec le budget bercy
mais ça c'est un débat et le fonds
stratégique je vous le dis de manière
très claire c'est le moyen de fixer
aujourd'hui un portage pour demain c'est
ça l'enjeu
alors aujourd'hui il sera à hauteur de
20 millions ça sera déjà quelque chose
qui nous permettra d'agir
mais bien entendu il faut que ça
continue à se développer et ça ça sera
des objectifs qu'on devra se fixer sur
le crédit agri dif et bien on a les
procédures additifs et donc on maintient
les mois j'espère qu'avec les nouvelles
règles sur la politique agricole commune
et 50 2 hectares on est aussi des moyens
qui ne laisse pas aller les choses
jusqu'à la difficulté mais qu'on
anticipe et qu'on permette d'aider c'est
ça aussi qu'il ya derrière
donc sur ce chien il n'y a pas de
changement sur les objectifs sur la
question des pme on est sur le même
montant et là aussi entre crédits de
paiement autorisations d'engagement on
est avec les cofinancements sur l'équipe
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure plus
d'engagement européen - l'engagement
français et derrière il ya le fonds de
modernisation
ça c'est autre chose le fonds de
modernisation au delà de l'histoire des
pnd eux ça serait dans la discussion qui
est ouverte aujourd'hui avec l'ensemble
des professionnels mais qui n'est pas
facile ça serait d'avoir un financement
du premier pilier pour alimenter la
modernisation et l'investissement et je
réponds à une question en même temps sur
à qui s'adresserait à ce moment-là ça
s'adresserait à l'ensemble des
productions dont les productions
porcines volaille et bovine
donc c'est ça l'intérêt du fonds de
modernisation et le débat porte sur
combien on peut en prendre du premier
pilier pour le mettre sur le deuxième et
financiers se font
sachant que là il y aura une négociation
régional les objectifs c'est de faire en
sorte qu'on ait des moyens au niveau de
la pac et qu'on y ajoute des moyens du
feader
et les régions sur cette modernisation
des bâtiments
alors j'imagine que par exemple sur la
bretagne sur ce qui est posé sur la
production porcine sur la volaille où il
ya des besoins de modernisation
d'économie d'énergie la l'environnement
mobilisateur plus jeu des bâtiments qui
sont économes en énergie plus je fais
d'économie ne sait pour l'environnement
et mieux c'est pour le producteur en
termes de bien-être de travail de
conditions de travail et d'économie
d'énergie donc on est vraiment dans ce
sujet mais là ça va être le couplage
entre les dispositifs 2e pilier avec un
prélèvement sur le premier et les
politiques régionales qui vont venir
s'adapter à chacune des régions
alors ça peut être par exemple sur la
filière foie gras dans sud ouest
aujourd'hui il ya des besoins
bon donc ça sera un arbitrage jade hic
ici à cette commission qu'on aura et
j'en ai convenu avec le président
rousset au printemps 2014
une grande réunion entre le ministère de
l'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire et de
la forêt et les régions pour cancale
l'ensemble de notre dispositif pour une
mise en oeuvre en 2015 puisque vous
savez fait adhère région plus politique
agricole +21 piliers plus promet piller
tout ça change en il faut qu on se cale
pour une grande politique d'innovation
d'investissement et ça se fera avec les
régions sur les crédits de franceagrimer
97 millions 87 +10 qu'asda on est à 97
millions les + disque hasard juge répond
si en même temps la question
on constate la recette sur place elle a
augmenté
donc on a on a juste et on a considéré
que le fait qu'on puisse qu'aller de
partie des 10 billions casdar sur
l'expérimentation pour franceagrimer ça
permet de garder à franceagrimer un
volume un volume un niveau de budget qui
est le même 97 millions et sur la digue
des 10 millions ducasse d'art on va
mettre en cohérence
l'action de franceagrimer avec des
agressions sur l'agroécologie donc c'est
ça c'est ça l'objectif qu'on s'est fixé
le cap à 1 re barrage via le constat du
niveau des recettes et vous savez que
c'est à d'excès au niveau du chiffre
d'affaires donc ça change et ça évolue
en fonction des années sur li chn
et sur les objectifs qu'on s'est fixés
est ce qu'il y aura compatibilité entre
les objectifs et le budget qu'on nous
avons ouï oui il ya compatibles
c'est un élément qu'il faut obtenir qui
toujours difficile a indiqué comme ça il
faut savoir aussi que quand on prend la
référence je le disais tout à l'heure à
1 milliards 5,7 du 2 du 2e pilier
sur l'année 2013 voilà quand je prends
la référence sur 2013 un milliard trois
sur le 2e pilier et quand j'ai la
référence 2014-2020 à 1,4 milliard mais
ça fait 100 à 150 millions s'est arrondi
mais le 1 milliard 3 / 2013 c'est le
maximum qu'on est touché sur toute la
période précédente puisque y aller on
est en fin de période est donc ce niveau
est extrêmement élevé donc on a les
marges pour pouvoir assurer et la
revalorisation de 10 sa chaîne tout en
mettant en oeuvre ce que je disais tout
à l'heure des cofinancements plus
important pour l'europe est moins
important pour notre budget sur les tv
engrais est-ce que ça touchant non ça ne
concerne que les amateurs les
professionnels agricoles santé sont pas
concernés par cette augmentation de la
tva jeudi déductibles c'est clair et
c'est net
oui ce sera sur les ménages et les seuls
qui perd au bout du compte c'est ceux
qui achèteront des engrais pour aller où
des anglais ou des produits
phytosanitaires sur dans les magasins
que vous connaissez bien et que vous
arpentez de manière régulière je vous ai
déjà vu alors / dpi dpa
ouais c'est césar ça c'est pour césar et
maintenant on va passer à un peu cher
sur ce qui est des pays dpa oui bien sûr
la dpa c'est très important
elle est mise en place un et ça fait
partie du débat qu'on a sur l'assurance
la prise en compte des risques
on a eu une réunion ce matin très
importante avec un certain nombre
d'acteurs pour savoir comment on mettait
en place que ce qu'on avait dit
d'ailleurs en gironde à la fois le
niveau confronte calamité la maintient
le système et comment surtout on crée un
niveau de mutualisation pour créer la
mutualisation il faut qu'on élargisse
l'assiette c'est tout le débat
pour élargir l'assiette il faut qu'on
ait des produits d'assurance qui
fonctionne et il faut que l'état soit là
pour assurer la mise en route quand je
comprenne bien on sera obligé de prendre
du premier pilier pour aller dans le 2e
pilier pour financer l'assurance je
pense qu'aujourd'hui les organisations
professionnelles agricoles sont d'accord
et on a intérêt de bien penser notre
système puisque à l'avenir une partie de
ce que sera la politique agricole
commune à l'échelle européenne
ça sera aussi une partie liée à ces
questions de se préserver contre les
risques le réchauffement climatique
aujourd'hui fait que l'intensité et la
fréquence des aléas sont de plus en plus
forte
donc c'est un vrai sujet et donc il faut
qu'on se prépare donc sur cette question
de la mutualisation pour élargir
l'assiette
on aura donc apprendre p1 sur p2
d'accord ça c'est fait on aura aussi à
faire en sorte que la subvention qui
vient et qui est incitative aujourd'hui
voilà ça sera alors c'est pour l'europe
a le p1 p2 c'est et l'europe et l'état
que cette subvention fur et à mesure
qu'on élargit l'assiette pour qu'elle
puisse être la plus large possible et
bien son niveau et 65 pour son joli par
contrat là il baissera au fur et à
mesure qu'on va élargir l'assiette en
même temps plus la société large plus
pour les organismes mutualistes en
particulier c'est intéressant pour
assurer la mutualisation
il nous reste deux questions majeures à
poser ou à régler plus tôt la première
c'est qu'elle sont quelles conditions
mais ton pour que les agriculteurs
soient ou inciter ou contraints à
recourir à l'assurance on avait discuté
est-ce que la rendent obligatoire vrais
sujets juridiques comme en un site
hélas les liens entre dpa et assurances
ça serait intéressant
vous avez la dpa où vous l'avez pas si
vous n'avez pas de dpa il faut
d'assurance cds question que j'évoque
aujourd'hui pour la première fois mais
c'est des sujets qu'on a bien en tête
il faut qu'on aille vers un système plus
large et puis c'est la question de la
réassurance derrière c'est à dire le
risque étant ce qu'il est si on
mutualise parce que je dis bien
mutualisés c'est pas de l'assurance
comme à brive et individuelles c'est de
la mutualisation pour l'agriculture la
question du risque c'est de la
mutualisation
chacun paye en partie mais c'est la
mutuelle
ce qui fait que on peut assurer la
couverture de risques climatiques c'est
très important ça et c'est l'assiette
sera la plus large qui nous permettra
bon ça sur la question de la réassurance
est ce qu'elle est privée ou publique
la ccr questions posées on va aller et
on va réfléchir par rapport aux
questions puisque ça concerne le
ministère de l'agriculture mais dès
qu'on passe à la dimension de la
réassurance
on tombe sur le ministère du budget de
bercy et du trésor et donc là il faut
qu'on ait une discussion mais on est en
train de construire tout ça parce que
voyez bien que c'est un système qui est
important mais je crois franchement pour
avoir été à bordeaux entre les deux
maires 1 sur une question comme la grêle
qui est historiquement assuré quand ya
pas de l'assurance parce que c'est un
fongicide 1 c'est ce qu'on me disait ce
matin c'est le coût d'un fongicide de
s'assurer et quand vous avez perdu comme
ça d'un seul coup d'un seul en une nuit
tout ce qui était le travail et notre
production
je peux vous dire que c'est un vrai
sujet vous avez des gens en larmes donc
il faut qu'on s'organise et pour
s'organiser
il faut connaît la solidarité c'est une
fonds de calamité la mutualisation c'est
ce qu'on est en train de construire
mais j'attends les propositions aussi de
la gironde puisque ça doit ça doit
arriver je suis sûr alors les risques
climatiques j'en ai parlé le fonds
stratégique sur la filière bois
j'ai évoqué ces questions en même temps
alors monsieur sur l'agroalimentaire la
bretagne bottle évoqué beaucoup de
choses la première je le rappelle ici la
question des restitutions la décision
que l'europe prend elle est prise en
2005 michel barnier a juste dit et je ne
savais pas avait rappelé que de toute
façon on irait vers la fin des
restitutions je suis obligé de constater
quand même ça je vous le dis franchement
je vais pas faire de la politique on est
là entre nous que entre le moment où ça
a été décidé et aujourd'hui il s'est
rien passé
personne n'a anticipé ce qui s'est passé
il ya la même aujourd'hui patron hier
soir qui vient dire seul mini c'est de
votre faute volet remettre des
restitutions
ah oui comme ça c'est moi qui gère t il
un coup tout seul c'est moi qui est
responsable si ça court je le dis quand
même sur les restitutions à
l'exportation
quand je suis arrivé en 2012 toutes les
restitutions qui était encore en vigueur
dans la viande bovine dans la viande
porcine
et dans tous les pays qui étaient
concernés danemark pays bas allemagne et
france ont été abandonnées la seule qui
a été maintenue c'était sur la volaille
et c'est à ma demande justement pour les
deux entreprises bretonnes qui ont
bénéficié et compte tenu qu à l'époque
quand je suis arrivé on était déjà en
redressement judiciaire pour d'où on a
tenu un an un an de plus que ce que
voulaient faire la commission
jusqu'en juillet 2013 en a maintenu et
j'avais prévenu je les dix 10 fois
anticipons regardons alors qu'en doux et
arrive en redressement judiciaire avec
c'est difficile pour lui de faut déjà
qu'on se remette et qu'on stabilise
cette entreprise et on n'oubliera pas
tilly sakho mais il ya des étapes qu'il
faut franchir
si je veux arriver à réussir à maintenir
une filière export sur le marché du
moyen-orient
ça fait 40 ans que ça dure alors après
on peut critiquer pour qu'on exporte du
poulet si c'est pas les français des
bretons qui le font sens et les
brésiliens qui le feront mais sans aucun
problème donc on a et en plus je le dis
ici eux en arabie saoudite et les
saoudiens en particulier al moulla jane
tiennent à avoir un approvisionnement
certes brésilien mais aussi français et
breton en l'occurrence et même doux pour
être plus précis à nous de travailler
avec eux pour construire un pôle export
qui leur permettent d'assurer
l'approvisionnement de leurs marchés
tout en permettant à notre filière de se
redresser mais c'est vrai soyons
objectifs entre 2005 et 2008 2010 2012
rien n'a été fait pour anticiper ce qui
était annoncé pourtant par tous la fin
des restitutions et deuxièmement je le
dis quand même on ne peut pas bâtir une
filière exportatrices uniquement sur des
subventions à l'exportation
1 c'est quand même un sujet sur lequel
il faut qu'on soit clair entre nous
alors sur les aides d'urgence oui on a
débloqué 15 millions on est prêt à en
rajouter
j'irai en bretagne vendredi pour parler
aussi des investissements qu'on doit
faire dans toutes les filières en
particulier sur la question de la
moselle méthanisation et la bretagne
sera expérimental au titre de ce que
j'appelle la zone totale avec le plan
emma la zone totale ça consiste à dire
quand j'ai de l'excellent de masse
d'azoté organique lisier tout ça
je le transforme en énergie renouvelable
au bout du compte j'ai un fertilisants
azotés qui doit se substituer
si j'en ai en excédent a offert ti
lisant azotés minérale la bretagne
aujourd'hui à trop d'azoté organique
mais elles importent et elle achète de
l'azoté minéral donc tout l'enjeu de la
loi d'avenir ça va être de mettre en
place le processus d'azov total chaque
région choisira si elle choisit ce
régime ou pas mais ça consistera ensuite
à faire en sorte que tout le monde
déclare les achats d'azoté minéral et
l'excellent d'azoté organique viendra
remplacer la zot minérale et je vous le
dis franchement je pense qu'avec ce
processus là si on se débrouille bien en
particulier pour la bretagne les algues
vertes
normalement dans dix ans je l'avais dit
la conférence environnementale
si tout ça ça se met bien en passe si on
coordonne nos objectifs si tout le monde
joue le jeu on doit pouvoir régler ces
questions
c'est très important et ça sera l'objet
de discussions j'aurais dès vendredi
pour mettre tous en oeuvre il ya des
projets en cours foucault nous mettre en
route
et puis voilà état région dont bien sûr
les régions seront mobilisés dans ce
dans ce dispositif
il y avait la question du casse d'art
donc j ai répondu l'eau et des fruits
c'est important est ce que l'équipe de
la nef
on y est alors on rajoute de 30 millions
de subventions aujourd'hui parce que je
tiens à ce que les élèves puissent
passer ce cap difficile
il se trouve que le marché du bois pas
forcément en prime on en volume en tout
cas pour ce qui est de zf ça va mieux et
que de ce côté là il ya eu des recettes
et donc on était il ya pas si longtemps
avec l'ensemble des représentants de m
c'était mieux c'est parce que j'ai quand
je suis arrivé c'était carrément est-ce
que l'ol va disparaître là on est quand
même dans un dispositif dans une
disposition où ça se redresse les 30
millions viendront assurer cette
transition
la vraie question est vraie question qui
est posée après c'est comment on évolue
au niveau de l'eau nf à la fois sur la
proche patrimoniale les ingénieurs la
gestion et en même temps vous savez les
ouvriers deux élèves qui sont aussi là
pour entretenir les forêts je pense
qu'il fera qu'on garde les deux on a
besoin des deux outils
et puis on va essayer de le construire
là maintenant ensemble mais loana va
mieux ça va mieux c'est
voilà pour cette audition de stéphane le
foll le ministre de l'agriculture qui
était entendu par la commission des
affaires économiques du sénat tout de
suite c'est le 24 heures c'est là